you're Tom said before sick of their  eyes may wanna debt ever can yield  wanting answers there don't need answers  they're dead  my son laid in the cold in pain for  hours and whoever did this is free  no one saw you right keep your mouth  shut and want to ask you what you're  doing in the park you told me a job it's  an accident my cup and a black kid I  don't [ __ ] accents anyway  a black teenager was left out in the  cold to die no one cares about  Breitenbach  his life does not factor into the  equation of this city you do my job  jobs locking up other cops town I didn't  become a cop to break the rules I'm  gonna turn myself in feel good cut  unique for a dying breed and we take  care of our own I want you to think  about what kind of father you'd be  behind bars  you're not gonna stop  - hue put them away  [Music]  you never know what happened  and the only one who might ever know is  God  God didn't run my son down in the street  and leave him to die  Amandla  [Music]  you